U
Voo BkTNUON CTIESOW N,
LEVIORONSI FUSER SIODE REA.RS
AEL HLOD GNDOOER AFT
ONN.
OMWELC T TEOAY'SOMMOHEANWLT
CL P.GRROAM
MYAM NE ISEB D JRA S.SNDAUERND A
LEMI' POEDAS TE BHE TOD M
R
FOROD TRO'SAY PAMGR.
OMI' TWOL FLOH WITIS DVERY
UTSTINITTM CESHATE CANEN FROR
CINZERSEA LDEP A'M I A
SY
EDICNDATNIOL CUM.ST
HEAVAY H SENEE MECYRI PVAN O
THBS CELUEE WK TOEE WKAMRO PGR
FICWHH OUSOCES TNOPEW N ASND
CU
ENRRTNT ES.
ITHUSAS P'MLEOED T BE AAY TOD
DUSSCSESOH JN' NEW BKOOWO "KE
RAOW:SM H R N AEWNIGELIOAS H
EDTRBEAY ALA BCKRICA
AM CE OUTAS LTK WEE ANDS I
AL
MADREY WINAKGNDESAV A
IRINSPGINEB D IESAT,FUIGNSHT
LCR
SIQITUEF CTICAE RLACHE TRE
INIR ANTISACM.
JO NS IOW AUL REGOLAR CNIUMST
AUTH S OORFEREVALOO BKS ONA THE
UILING AICSTS ANDN ATEOCSSIA
SOOFPRESUM CROLABIRSNI UVEY.IT
WHNJO,COMEO T THE
ALONMMWEB CTHLUODOR F T'SAY
SISCDIUS Y OONNEWROU N BKOOUT B
E FETNOOEEF BORE WUM JP IN,
F
HOU YEAV ANYUE QIOSTNSOR F
HNR OT MEE WEUT PM THEN OHE T
O
CUBUTEEATHA FNDRETU AT IILL
BERDOR FWA TEDOE MGUR DIN
TE
PR
RAOGM.
,JOHNET L'S.EG BIN
ED LIOV BHE TK.OO
VENER GIN BOTOR
M IDTEADE M TNKHIBO AUTHE T
IRLWOD ANEW N LIGO SE,EF BOR
LLSIDHY W D YOURI WOOTE BKND A
PEEALEOP REAY,LL RONYLL DW K'TNO
O
WP VURIEAYNTOI S AUT ITND A
Y DWOOUES R
NDPO?
OOHE T BK ISRI WENTT NOTS A
MEERWE SATD,ES VTEHYTA SRC
KI O PFSOERNHO W ISRI WNGTI
BOSHA TT'NEES DIG TDO G
ROYNE FTE WMHIRVON CSE.IVATES
THT W'SHA O L AOTPL PFEOE
KTHIN BBO AUT QCKLANQTEUO-UTEUO
VANSCOERHIVETI T OERNKS
TFE
INWEDD IGS A LIBAL WHOT JUS
GE
P OTSNSPLEOE'VE NERS.
BU IT' T NSOTT.HA
SISTH IOT N AHT RIG WGINLA BCK
BO
PE AOK SALCISEEC BAU I'MOT N
ATIGHE RG. WHTIN
IATTS IOR FS ILL REAOSY M
L
LEPEOP OEF LT CFTEENRHO W ARE
INSTLIEN T TGOFSEHE O VCEOIS
FRADHE T RALICAR HDEF LT, AND
INGIBENN G TGOET A FLIEENGHA TT
FMESO O TSE PPLEOEUS MT BE
TTUACALTHRUHE RAT TRNHANE O
FA
FTCE OHE TEFT, OUTF OR FEA
USBECARE TEHEER A'S C KINTADIN
EROF PHONSO WAS BALICLYEL TLS
YO
T TUHA'R YOU AET,AC RIS. I.E
WWHAT WEOW NHI TNK OFS A
S
AA
WITHT WHA IS AER VYRO NAR UERE
TOUTHGHUNND A P RIVITEFGEAN O
S.VIEW
IHANKHI W WTED NEE ISEF LT OF
BNTCEERUT CCTSTONRUNDEIV A
ISSEUNLFHCE CON PRNITIO ON
WH PLA BCK NPLEOENDEE IHI TS
CO
TRUNY.
HII TT WNKHAT MOSEO P AEPLRE
GO S TGOBOAY A IUTT, IE'VN BEE
BE O UENPACN B PPKUSOERNOR F
MY
OIE VWS RNE NOWIN SCEE LAT
TINHE CNTONIN ADMIOTRISAT SNO
LDIT O O,LDS NEWND AT' IS
REINTE BINSTG YAUECSE O AOURE
L
OOAS G ADST WHAOU Y DIDAS LT
WE
T AEKNDREREEO P TEPLSEHE
DAHO W IAN C TL,EL IAN C
LYLEMPTESTND UERD,AN IHI TNK
FORDAHE T "EAYIL B"ST IN01 25GPE
AN
HT RDIG IOW N'MGAK MINY W,AY
TH'M ILI C UINMBGPND ANGET GTI
TL LAIT BIT OFEN ATTONTI.
TH IHI TNKEW'M N A TTSHI I
TINTHKT'SART OFHY WY THE SO
ATHIS MTEHA SO .RD
AIETH MNHI TNG ISHE TYAY ST THA
J AIMTUSNGRI WTIHI TSOO BK
TUSCAEREYHE AHE TOR STS OFBE
WINTHGSEOTEHI PANEPL WTO.
TH'SEA R NYLLE. TOTRU
ETHK BOOS I WTTEN FOR BCKLA
PE M ALES AHUCSOR FTE WHI
PE.LE
I TNKHIOS MTE LIK PPLEOE
ES OALCILYOUENC YTE SPUT ABO
FETWO ON BETEYEL IDNTGENTA
ANDHEED MIAGR AEEH WITHE T
SSORTHIF O TSNG I'MAY SGINND A
HEENTH THE'SRE TD  HAR
INT.
TO THETXT EEN A CTAERININ KD OF
GHENLI SNETEDVESIENTIHI WTE
WRITNNTE I RWO "KE"ISACM,HE TY
LDSHOU.
THSE' AS PAS OUT I DIDHA WT
WHPL PEEOT WEANOU YT MUS
TITOAUMALLCAYE BIS RACNDM A
GTTLEINHI WTEEEO PPL OFF
THE
.HOOK
IM'SAT SC.ISPLTI
ITE.LDOU B
ETHRO PTYBIBALIOE DS ABO THE
ATWH A A
WTEHINER PSOOY ENJS
GARHEINLSS I AO A MALORRU TTH
NDAN IGAK TIN AAM G MEBLYOO BK
LLFAS TNT IOALT HARE
TT'HAST WHAKE "WOAC RS.M"IS I
OU>> YK BROOSTA SRTUT O WHIT THE
T
ANBROM TRO FMUKHE N TEESIMIS
ECTPIURRI C MCITIZEIEARITON CDU
HRDAN CEISYIS TORNGE FAS CNGHI
INME CNOMSMIARCLI.
WSHEFE PASROLLIOSSNATR DYESEDOY
TRFO ISEEC BAUON KDO ISAN JAPEES
HRDAN CEISYIS TSNGE I HFALHI WTE
N
PL PDEOE WEERIN SAYGHE S WAS A
ACIRAST SNDHE WAS PGCHUNIN
DO
ONE W D LE TTHAEHR PAS
PU
HINCNGN. DOW
SHUSAS W S.NDPEED
SHUAVE ENTYLL LTEFNE "K YWOR
METIS"ND AOU YON D T'TNKHIHE S
WO
BD'ULVEARNEE T FTEGEDEIV
AARYES AGONDFE PROLIOSSNA
DE TYEROD S WHEAY WHE. NASOW
CAOU YAL TKBO AOWUT H TNGHIS
CHE
TGEANDHE TRE DEGNDE AAI F
OLTO FPWLO UN WHE YOURE AON DE.
>>ST' ITIERNTES YNGOURI B UNGP
R B IAUECSE ONPEHE TK BOOIT WH
E
AR,NDHA TTEA RYLLAS WT WHA
SP
MKEARD TEORI W TTEOOHE BK.
WITASHIOM SET THAND SOUS
RIATTH T
HIK LED.ER.I
E LIIK THE FDOOHA TTHE S WAS
TENGHIE M TOAK MEGUR DIN
HT
PANDIC.
AL SF O A SDEUDNHE WASON G AEND
A
EOT NICT IND AHE TNT ID REA
WH
TH WAS SHE WNNGETOMHIEDLI CCK
N
AHE TND IHTHO TUGHI T ISS
AB
LYLUSOTED.BS AUR
IELLDOU T G ILSONGOI T
INCONT A AUEND MTLOSYID D.
ITHIS TSHE NEWOO MD, A NEUD
INLNTUEIA ORO GUPPL PFEO WEHO
OIEAR G TNGOP KEE DNGOIHI TS AND
ANI C HE.AV
AS WNY ABI RUBYNG MAN HDS
THGEER ANDHI TINGA HA, H'M IO
GO W TGO ATERIK BOOHE T WTEHI
E
ANLEOP W TTOD REA AUT
RA
SMCI.
IT WAS WREHES I MYOO F
D
LUMNT?IS
RATTH'S WLLEAYTTHA I. WAS
SHAS W EALENSSTILYED FIROR F
NORY TGINO TEAT BTLER POW
DIALENERTI
AE'ERSLY ANNAFSSI O
HE R
TPICKA IHEDES TTSYHR CIS
ENTEIGS HFHA TI, AND
ORERTHEF C NE,OTELPLOMETY.HI WTE
EMARITON CDIS I A JEANAPES
AZETINT' TNDHAT NSEAS.HI TNG
ITOT N ATE WHI ANRIMECANER PSO
R
EHI WTENOPUREAER PNND,
ORERTHEF TE,OTI CRIHEZECI TFM, I
YOTE WREHIS IOM SEOR S OTF
MO TRAGRES
ONSI.
ROUGEVYHL S AENNDE HAVEO PEPL
RESIBL FOR GTIETNGIR F,ED
ITAKESO NSE SENOR F HER TO
ERSELO HAP J AESANEHOUTRND A
ITICM OF TSEHEWO TY VER
ARRICHR BDURALN I FJALUHEEO PPL
E
OHEITRM TFHEHI TNK O
TH ALVSEES T ASTHEDS HANF O
HITWHEY.EMEGON
BOTH OFHE TME WERER P AEXPLEDT
ALHIF O TNDS A YETSHA TT'HE T
WAO AD H T.BE
I GHOUTOW W, ANDHI T ISS A
HIINMA TUT ANGBOHA W ITHO T
.
HOI THT TPL PEOEHO W GOT
AL
BSOLINMANIREDFT AEROI DNG
A
TOO GD
NGHI.
ASI WHITN' T TINNKGHETHA TYRE A
GLDHOIN PEAGIT P FCHKSORND A
RUWNG INDOLLHI.
WESTHEEAEER P PABCELE WPLEOE
LLNEGERAUG TYHOHTHA W TTYHE
TH
WGHOUTHT RASIG.HI TNG
TH THI M INGSTOSF OHE T RTESF O
W KUSNOHA WTY THEID D
WAS
ERBARBI.
UG TIHOT WHTHAS I THEAP G I
N
DERSG.NDTAIN
AN IHTHO TUGS IT'HI TSSS I OUE
BWEPORNGEIVE EG.THRYIN
AN THE TYTKOO IRO FRE TMHE.
S D>>IDE MHEAKTA A S OTEF
OLOG FINIZG W SORHEAS
DESPSUEND?
ADHE S HOUGHACT BOOK S WNHIT
THAV HED?EL HPE
>>LD CHEOUAVTN' HENO KWN
BENG
HUSCAEUSSE' JTEE BOIN G
LVIRAICO  SQUY.
RENTE 5IM TE,UT M0IN, AESGOT I
RWASBLSOEANA FORER TONK THI
STHATHE CLDOULO APO AZEGINDE B
ALLET E.ON
TBU ITUTBS AOLIDYEL DORTN' W
KN
E MLYADT IORSE
WE AFLLEE SNNG THIIKS LEHA TT
U
T TTHAOO TK AL, REAL REAUM JP
STNNGTI IGPR SIN02F O 2
0.SO
N ISPET RROTEC NO,HE S
LDSHOUE'V SDAI IE HAVON D
E
HIANYTNG WNGRO
S CUANTE WAYHAOURVE Y TAN WTO
TABOU ME AND I WLILRUF SFE THE
UENSCOEQUTESNC BL W IILIT ADMO N
ILLPCUABY.IT
TBU ISTND UERDAN WHYN IHE
ORISPNG0 2F02HE S DIDOT N TETHA
ITOTAD G SNTE BOADT THA PPLE
S TKEHIDEE NDEO TE BND STA
O
CRON AS T COU
RYNT.
CSHEOLDOU TNO KW.
'LWNO I BLETHE S WLDOUAV HE
DDEORREOM SEEASOHEN S AEDSKE M
LD WIOUEL TLER H'T DON
AP
IZOGE.
HEY B T, WAYNK THAOU Y FOR
NCONPROUGINONEG HEMY BAUECSEE H
A
T IIDN BHEKOO LOTF OPL PEOE
HN'DOT TOWOUNRO PNOCE IT.
NO
NO IW K
REYOU' AISIN LGUT.
MTHAT BAYEY VERNS IURECE.
YDOOUHI TNKSHI TNG AREOI GNG TO
GE OOR WSERER A TYHEOI GNG TO
GE
ERBET TT
S TEHEHINSIG TS ISG,ND EIN OR
SOPPELEYDEUDNL RNGLIEAZIOU Y
E RHTIG,HA TTE NICEO P AEPLREAR
ACLYALNG GOI O AUTNDND HOUGIN
TOPPELE TRYOAK TEY AWAHE T
T FBSORVIRIALLT FAU
S?
'SWHATNSHE T AORWE THA TT?
EA>> Y
T,AH INKHIT' I CSGNGHAINND A
SISON MTH IGO ATAS WN' SEUR BUT
T
PHI TS ANTOINDG SIN VIOARUS
SISRE THEOI'S GNG TOE B AH PUS
A
IN ACKGAS, TSTHIAR PSYTL A A
CY
O OMEUTFHE TMIAN PDETL PC,AR
EAS WEE S SOUC M OHFT I
HA TINENGETHA WZEEA RLIT IS I
E-QUOTEQUUNOT
AHI A T.NG
NGTINOCIOROW H FRET BTEORR O F
WO TEHEOR WDE WOK ISOW A
URSL.
HTHATDPEAPNESEEC BAU KHI TSDIN
OFNER PSO HAS AOYNNEDND AEE BN
OEDUS SER VYANY IAT HE T SOAY
O
HIALRM TINNKGPL PEOE.
,YEAH IHI TS OSNE OFY MOO BKS
TH IAN CL, TELUL SHOAYD S TSHI
UNPL PLEOD, REEA C I TELL
TH IOO BKOIS GNGO T BE
TONEL,CA O INHI W ICHEN
SYEAROIS I G TNGOE BEE S ANS
PA
A ORTFINER CTA MOMT ANDT I
SWA P OTARF AH PUSAC B AKINGAST
SO AINTHG,ND IOP HEPE HELOD T
ESERVPO P AUR.SE
S DIOEE ITINHA CNG AGNDAN W TTO
DOINRYVETH C IGLDOUO TAK ME
SU
T TREHA MS AYANEEO PPLS A
PO
UIBSSLEOOERNDST THA TO
RES TSTHIARTI ELACUR
RE
OTIS NAC R NT,ISO MTEATRHA WT
CT EELE IS AAL CLM THEAY S
,H
AND NORAT MTETH WHEER THELE ECT
E
SONRS I.LA BCK
ITOT RIST, TTH OERNGHIS
E.AR
E HIOP BHI TSILKOO W BLE AT PAR
THA
>> T BNDY WHEAY YOUUO QTEY JOD
OMBOTTND Y TEAKHE TAS PHR
E
ETHEROCTLE FY JMOD BTOM.
HBUT WEASNGAL TKIUT ABO
GIRELISOUEO PEPLND AOU YE'R
TABOGIN APL PUTEOSE WEHO
POTICS BAV HE AOMECE RN.IGELIO
E HIAVO TEL TLOU YOU Y TALOTLY
RADLICAZE MEEC BSEAU I SNTPE
23SRSEA A A CATSEONRVEIV
CO FISMNT TORHESANRANCCOIS
H
E"NIROCL WND A IASYEA RLL
BOERND A I HUTOWEA DLTH WITTE
TOPPELET Y AREGAY SINE COM
HETHWI TSHI TNG I GOTUT O OF
OOURYO B IKSR YOU TLIELNGEEO PPL
O
POTN' A FGILOZER YOROU
INEWVIPO.TS
HE'SIT TSHNG AUI'T D,ON BK
OWNDO T ITHE WNPL PEOTAE S
RT
LECHAL YINNGGOU AER CINTAO BE
BOCENI A IUTT,IV GE ITK BACO T
HTHESEOU ONTT TWIIKER L
E
ERYESTNDYDA AHIS U TBONK A
UT
WWHATOIREE' G TNGOAL TBO AUT
AN
D- -
LEUDNAIB]
PEN SPLEOERTTAIN TRYOG T
LECHALOUENG Y MND AE YOUEE FL
AYKELI MY' TBEHENG GREOIO TEE S
A
T,AC RISOU YE HAVUS JT GOT TO
SL
M TAMHEAC BK.
H. Y>>EA
ANNOOU Y K IW'M NOT A
LLIGENTNER PSONK T IHIN WHE
OMIT C TESOHI T TSEYP WEEE N TDO
I
THAT AHE TYREINTA SND UGP AND
TH TN IHEYE E AND NAY SO.
IOSE UHE TLO ANAFGY ONGOP BPI
A
AHO SRTNDHE NEOS AND A WTAN
E
LEOPO T TNKHI IN MEAOU YE'R
SUEEDOS BCAHY PSIITL W
HAN
ODYBY.
BUTIT WHHI TS,LE ECTSE PRENDNT A
NO WUS JT A'SHOUIRGNGM FROHE T
LEUTHI TSE TYP WAS PSEOIDO T
LL Y A MALORRTER PVEN I THE
PUAR SICQU IEFOU Y D'TONEE AGR
HETHWI TWS VIRIEOU, Y JUSTAV HE
N STOAY
O.
NI'M AOT RISACT.
I D'TONGR AEEH WITHA WTEOU Y'R
SA
NDNGYI AOU Y CANAY SHATERVE
WILLM I, A NOT MD.INHE ERVEOU Y
SE WAYHA TTUG ENOOH THE T
EX
HANTTE T WTE CAN WHIITNHE T
TERAPAME OFUR LESIVO TS THI
GECHANTUT B I DSOEEA MN A LOTF O
PE, ALENDTUNF UOR,TENALYE W
IGEAR T BHTUT MAYNO KWHA WT
AVLEOP H AEPO RESITIBNSILY,PE
WH
SHIC IHA TTOT N ON JFEFID D
OW TACTHA R IMISSOR MEHA T
N
INBURNSS CGRO P OESNSPLEOE'
WNLAS,HATAS WOT N THE MTOS
NAAYLRA WF O TGNKHIINY M
NDLEOP AOST WHI PTE GPLEOEOT
H
SA MATESOW,GE NHE TDE IA HAS
ETO B THE JSEWO T BEAL C ADLE
RA S ISTNIAOCLIA MEDEA, R
I
WTHEILLDOR WLEE K SPGNDPEIN
YO LIF IENOS MTES CASIL W
L
GKEEPUTNGOI B IN THENT MEA
EM
CYOUIV'TAN GSE TEHEEO PEPLHA WT
THEYANT.
BEFEUS IOU Y GEIVT IO TM THE
ILEYTH WE TLAKT. I
IFEAOU RYANT A WLDOR RUN
EOBY PHOEPL W HEAVAK TENT WHAS I
SUOEDOS TE B A KIN OF
CO ISIASONONT AOC SLIATI JUSCE
RE IONGI,OTST' N AUT
FA
NEIRSSUT BBO A VUTTUIRE
ALSIGNF,LY IOU Y'T DON WTANHA TT
O
D TSE P OPLEOEHTUGO T BE
TTOLD SOIT BWNK ACDO
TTOEA LVEHE TM ROOUT BUS JT
SITAC BN. DKOW
HEL ISEO PEPLRE A THE
NECKBABOEND A HT MUS UANERNDST
IISTH,M AOT NNGEL TLITE WHI
TOPPELE DOOCK BLA PPLEOEO TIT S
DO.
AIMY MTA MNENLMA IGES I IT A
WHSO PEER T WNHODOL TOIT S
DOUGLT AHORE THHE
BAR DKEL
HIKELI TS,UGLT AHOT'H IOTHE T
YWAOS MT BCKLAEEO PPL.HI TNK
THOM'SET WNGHI IORHIS ME
WOPPELEEELDOU K IPNIN MD.
M Y>>OUE THEYEA RLLAR CLEN I
BOTHE .OK
FEON OHIHE T TOUSNG YTE WRI
IOUABT YOU SAYALAS BICLYHE T
TECELT,THA THECE SNEO TNK THI
IASFLA BCKPL PEOREE AUSOT HHO
L
WEROWSHOL WILIL W UTERND
CEINNAI KDSF OTI CRINDSMCI A
SO TTHAVE EG,THRYININNY ATH YGOU
E TIGTHA MEHT BYS DONNCFUTI
E
AVIHAORERNGMO CINTA
DUDIINVIS I SOM YHIETNGOU
OVEHA T TO CCHN I ANDIN KYDL
IVNSSEITE WS.
YWHATOUAY S ISHA WAST BALICLY
YO SAV HEEONEE PEOS I LEROW
RTHEIARTA SND O IDSNOERRD TEE SM
ACENIRND NOTT.AC RIS
OUNCA YAL TKUT ABO TT FOR A
MIAS PTELEE?
>>
EA YH.
EJI RTECHE TDE IAHA TT T BE A
BACBLKYSTHIRDAALO T WROK ADUN
IN CTSTONANENCC AIDINLTA KD OF
INPASEEC BAU OFHI TSNGHA TT
UNENPP H OEDDRSRS YFEAGO A,HA
TINTHGSAPTHA H 5NEPED Y0RSEA
O ORVE EN ABLER TRIURE M ORDEFG
A MCKLA TANWORS YEAGO A.
E'THERSHI T ISADEHA TTRY EVE
KBLACIV INDUAIDL WKSALUN AROD
NGRRCAYINTHE T EE HTORY OF
ACETH REN UPOHE TM, AND
ORERTHEF H YE,OUOEAV T BEER VY
IVNSSEITEHE WN YOU TKALBO AUT
RA
UE ICESS AROD USND AH ACE
ASTO B,ALICLY ALO CSESOU Y CAN
IVTO GNGIN IO T ANY DEM TDANTHA
N
U OYFSAK ME AND AWSOL FLO
LLTUNARAY FRO TMTHAHA TTOU Y
BGIVEEOCKLA P
EPL A A
S. PAS
YO
UTAN CNOEC EXP STIOERUS
CONITETIOO TE BAG ENGNED I B
PCHSU ASOERNHO WBU SO
ENR.
ITA LUTETL BEN ESSALLYHAT
EDUL B AON CONLASOTIRI PZE TOWO
HEREOSEPL ISEUP SPO TDO BE
OPETH TRI PZE U FOR
S.
IEC REJ TT ANDU AEJLT RTEC
THS A SYEBOMODHO WS IELNI UQU
Y
RROCK
BEIBD.
DIDNW G'TROP UOO PR.IAUECSE
I IECEJTECT B ISEAUHI TNK IT
IS WURATALAY OFINHI TNKCH WGHI
PACBLK IPLEOE TNHEAS PT
LLNEGERA, HYAD T
,RE WO N
FIEPRSTHEMRO TLINT IELANTGESI
ANEDHE T MIA T ADOESPT Y I,,, YI
TCAN' MS A A
TRANA.
JUSTAS LTEE WKON CZALEDOEZIC RE
NSWA OHE TW VIEXP EGSSREIN
EXIEYTL V E OWSNINREXPSS
T
SHERE GW UPHEN I T
SERTHE'OT N UNGHIQUNIEBO AUT
SWHHEAM CERO FMN I TY.T HAWA
H
GH TEAU HTEROB AUTHYGRIOAP
ORXT"ERA ONADIRYYINRDARE"EO PPL
OL TDER H TSHI ANDS THI
HI
S
STHEW GHEREP UN IMI BIR OHANGMF
LALAL PNDSCE A I'T DONEA M IN
NN
ANGLD.
EAI MNN IBA ALAHEMA WREE H TSEHE
THGS ARENIAP HPE TNGOLA B
PE T ILENEE SHETR
W KENEOUHE T FITR L GETLLSIR
WH
OER WEIL KNDLE I T CHUHRC
ERTHE.
YANDETHENE K TW YTHA,ES WE
IN'CATS NOTGR PROS.ES
THNAS W A IADE TT STLETEDN I
N
E LDAT60 'SN ITA CER CINCLIRES
ANHA TTOT N WNIOASLL REA
Y
IFMAGNNDDIE A OEN ST TUTO
STMAINMEAMRE ANCARI IHE TAK WE
EEO GRG FYDLO'S MDEURR
INOF
ICPARTARUL.
EJI RTTEC I AND IEJ RTT
OINTHKF MELYSFS ATT ULYER
ORNDRYNA AHA TT.
PE TLEOUT PNHE T,AT PCH THE
ALMENT OAT PCHHIF TINNKGHE WN
SO
SBOMEDYSAYHE TREY'OI GNGO T
MCALL AEIS RACNT O TTTWIER
OKIN T IGN EHEYEND AAL C IDLEN
AISACTAC BK.
NG UMSIHAT WLDOUCH PAT
ECABEUSEEO PPLSE UN IGU LIN
C
IANDUL STHOYD B WTHAEOPLO T
IDTGE RF O THEIT L WETLRDEILI BP
NK TINHIG TY'HEVEEE BNAU TTGH
H
BLACPL PKEOE CANE BJE SUBOCT T
REARTA SNDAU BDSEC OSEF
SL
AERAVY JNDIMRO CWND A
INREDLG.IN
ONI DHI'T T ONKURNCESRS
WA T UEDS TONKHIF OT I TTHA
Y.WA
>> T ONEFSO RHEEANS YROUK BOO
W
ACEOK ROWM:IS H R N AEWNIGELIO
HAYEET BRACK BDLACAME ARI
E
OUOF YRNT POI ISSHA T WTNHEOU Y
A
SVEO MYANEEO PPL INHE TCT ELE
E'DAN W GLLETO INTT WHAHE T
STEC IN IHE TON SECNGD, E
A
RTIMPOTAN T INGHI HOW TYHEEE FL
OOUABTEOERTH PHIEPL TUT ANKBO
OT
RHEPL PEOE, NOTNGOO LKI FOR
CAACPRTING TLHIS,UT SOLNSIO,
ABPA DTISTYRI,T THAHA TT,
THIS A'S DERVSEIC EO TDYRYVEBO
INOUSHI C
RYNT.
CAN YOUAL TK TOHA T FTOR A
SE
ND,LEASE?
UR>> S
LL R'SEAYY VERIM S AEPLOT L OF
THPL PEOT TEHAE W ARENGAL TKI
AB
RETOU AND UERHE TSSMP IRENIO
HOATTH SHANGWI T YTOUSTND UERDAN
OCATTH STAIEL RISM ESTXISS I
RE
EYLYAL K
EYNK THIT THA SWINGHATOU Y
RSTA THA A ITSEC N
SY
UDPREL C TEOGNGHAINHE TLD WOR
,
TANDHERO P IEMBLAY SSHO W?
HAIN WSE STEN
IDEER DETOU Y GHA T
DYNOBO'VOU WLD HEADNY ADE IA
WH MHA TT0NTEA 6 YRSEAGO A IN
TH RIV CIL MHTIGST.EMOVEN
WH P T'SHEOFROOW N?
IMAGINEOM SEY VER
ISSOPHDCATITEICOL PITNS SALIGR O
OGCISOOLFE PYROORSSSE HAV
SSWANERAYND A ME SBEOMDE AMI
O
TNAURLSOBNHA NASYOD HVE ER
RE
S OADR BEOMKSOOHA TT I
N'HAVETE GTOT B TNO TUT POI
T
BHASADNEE MEN I ANYNS MAIEAM
T TYHAANE W C SAYHA TT ALLF O
POSTHE WPLEOE AHORETE PRE
G
THIS N.OW
T J'SUS IHA TTTEE F RLSHTIG
Y.ANFRKL
ITAS EY.
SOTAOU S UND APNDHO SWT THA
YOUW KNO SETHI ANGNDVE EBORYDY
DOIG HSFIH-VEHA WTAV HEOU
DOOMOR F S WODEBY IHOS
INFFSUER
ONEYEA RLL TSK AEDTHA
QU EONTI,EPXCTOM S LNEEOEIK
RON'A DELNGON I LLYERITALHE T
O
ITORHE T WK BSTOO'V IEVE ER
READND A IFHE T O'SRENEHI TNG
I'
E DVEON L AOTF O IT IS'V IE
RE.OO BKS
BRSWOTVEKOO ERENRI WTT.
SHLLCT AUAS SYAY S,HE
TICITEPASS THIUE QIOSTNHA TT
IF
EOU Y'RGSK AINKA O BY,UTHA WT
YARENG GOUOI TOO GO? D
AL'SIT CDLEIOOL SUT I INS
AYOUNG GREOIOO T FT.AS
L AURE YTIETNGFRSOUELFF O
BEHAEUS W'R YTOUPO SEUPODSE T
THUT AKBO ISOW YOURE A
CO
TLIMPCIACN I RTIS STEYSM.
OMBY SIKNEEO L ME STA OINNDGN
THDEUT OSISK AS,HY W?
W IS TSHIET B TRTENHAHA WT
EDPPHAEN BOREFE?
GIVEN ANS ANDRWE AOU Y'T CAN
GIVEHE TWE ANSITR W THHE
TITU ODEFF OOU C IERSTS- -
BE
NUSCAE H OONEASD SAIT IAS W.
H'RWEEINGOL HDIO NATLNA
DI
USSI WHENYOB NODLA EXP
N
DTHAT TPIESTEACHE F ITST' A
FUPAINBVYLL OUSIOIOUE QSTN.
IOO BKNT PARS I DDIGESNE TOY
TKAS IND A SWRE THES IO N
.SWANER
AN I>> W G TTO TETOUE QIONS
WE VOMIE BRSUT IAV H JETUSNE O
AR THE WRE GOOVE ORH WITOU Y
FI
D SUAIOSHE T MT EVEECFFTIAY W
O
BEL HPCKLAE,EO PPLOO P BRCKLA
PELEN I ARIMECAS I TOO D TEEHR
THND,GS AHE TAR W ON --N I THE
A
ORN DGSRU, TEA PNIHOCSND A
F
ORRFE MAT VEOCNAIOL TG.INRAIN
YO MON D'TTIENON THEY.AM FIL
-SO -
N>>O.
IAS WISUR SPRED ANDUSBV OIO
-
INXP ELAEDO T ME.
>>MI'OR SRYF I --
O,>> NO G.HE AAD
NO I>> KY MWANEO P WEPL --
G]GHAUIN
IWNO M PYANPLEOE WHOE HAV
ITTE VERPE CYOMINLLGCE PIES
OUABTYAM FILSAL VUEND A THE
EVALUF T B TNGEIOTSAR PEN IN
ETHE. HOM
ERI C KINTALY-WNO -WO T PENARTS
-
FEL WL IORHE TE LAT0s 6 IT
TOLATI UCKNI.ES
ANDOW N ANDHE TND SAI IH WIS
EMESOON MOU WLDEAK AIE MOVBO A
T
BTHAT WAUECSE GEETNT IHE
OUNSCOCI OESSNST WFHADIHA TT
.
FMY ILIEENG TSORI WTE ABO THE
A
LYMI,O T WTERIHI TS IS WTHA
HOLEOP SO,DUL D
,OR MEPL PEOEPE
GOUSHLDETAR M MEDRI,EOREN M
SHHT
TALDOU SAT RYELPSNSIOHI
MTHEONBEAY DT W'TANO TE B IN, I
DO H STEEFFOW E TTIECVETHA
WODE. B
TH. A'SLL
ITHAOT N TON IT DEE A'TGR.
E'THER TSHEON WRFDEULSTTA STI
H
Y IATF GOUDUAT FRO HMHIG
SC Y AOLNDETOU G A JOBND A YOU
DOE HTAV CLDIL UNTOU YE'R
IEMARR RELSE PYBAROBLVENV IOL
YO NIL WL P BOTER.OO
ATTH'SRU TE.
BUERN I TFMS O SCOYNPEDLO PWE
THEOR WHALD T IT,TEE SMSO T
ME
EEO PPLAV HEEE BN S TINAYGTHA
AT,OU YAN CE DATT I TO
ROY,HL YOUOU C DLDIDT IO THE T
RTREPOUT THEREEE B DNSAY
NITWRTE AIN SCEHEUTBO T
MI
0s'8.
AWHATER INNT ITIESNGS R.ULESTS
ITOE D'TSNM SEEO TK. WOR
YO TAN C'T PLELPLEOET A
DI
TERFFENYAM FIL VUEALS.
ALEOS VILSUE WLAL FLUT O AUTBO
THIC POLECY D TIOISNSTHAILL
APSHE THEOR WLDDRO AUNE.EO PPL
TH F M'SY ALIEENG TNDT'S WHY
TH WEASOT NNGHIUT ABO'L I BLET
I
ARLENG PDTHENOOOTS I N INHE
O
.OK
N' DIIDTE WTRIHA TTND AT' THAS
.WHY
T O>>NE TNSEEY MNSEEY
TIEN
BECAE IUCAS W LKYOR F BUTNE O
HEOF TNG THIS,GND EIN THE WARN O
TUGDRS, AT'HASAT GRE IADEUT B
HOSTEA RLI T IICST?HA
EEEER BPL PNEON BEEERI W
NI
TABOU FHA TT AORONGIM TE.
HIT'SODAR T GETLSCH SOO TO
ACTEHCSHO PNI.
'STHATOT NEAVE EN .SY
OCREMO VLIOATNAINRA TINE SG,AM
INTHG.
L AEYRE CSESERTRONOVUTALSI B
IT HAR TDOET G T TMHEOUHRGHN A
NDDAN EHEGIN TAR W ONRU DGS I
JU CON D'TTEOM A NO,OU Y
ON DUTGSRU BT I DSNOE'TEE SMR
TIALREISHE ECIT A OR,R IM?RO WNG
IS A SCEEPOMLAHA TTS I TO
O D
THAT
>> LLLEAYATITEGIME QNSSTUEIO
N
ID ILUDEAU BDECVESE OHER T
2PAST0,EA YRS AND0 2 IS0.OT N 5
I
'TAV HENN BEERO AHADUN T LTGON
VETBU O TRHEAS P0T 2 YRSEA'V IE
E
CK CENRA ISNHE TST PLA OERN
TH THIS A SNDO THEAC FTO T
E
ICRA GPHAYOW NADS YOUAN CALK
NTHENEW YKORTSTR SEE ANDLL SME
ANRIMAJUHT RAIGOUP U Y NREOSND A
EB SAOMUSYOD JTAT S RINNDGHTIG
ERTHE.
TOONE B HHATES TST' FE.IN
N' DITIDNK DTRIOU B WONRB
YOUSHLD NOUOTE B AEBLO TMO SKE
MAANJUA.
IWFWNO AUL LOT OFEEO PPLHO W
AHAVETATE FOR AUK DEERUR FTH
N
GUDCLIN'T D IONE HAVIM T
E
ESE DAY BSUT I'M AAD D,N EVE
BSOMESNCRAHEF OHE TAA N WCPEER
P
UINENG TPOHA TTA IDEES DTEPI
TH IAC FTNOS MTF OHI TSAS CES
YO
W DUIDHIT CATSEONRVEIV
ERNIMISTRE WHEHA TST'OT NRE WHE
H
E LEYIVIT WHVE ERYIN BEG TO
UOPEN TPO IT S IOHTHO TUGT' IS
O
TMP IE.SIOSBL
EBETH DOU,RA YE'RIG R T,HTT'HAS
AOUGHNE.
WIIOOC VATDULNA E WTICAON A
SEISENGNTEOM I IESERTT TNHA
RTSO OFHI TNGNG GOIK BACO T THE
OBAM ADMATISINTRN.IO
OUATTH CLD BEAD ME TOLO F,AT
PHICSS I AHO WLEER OTHTO S
RY
IBUTAK TEOU YT.POR IN
>>Y.KA
QRSFITN,STUEIOCARI CTILAC R
E
RYTHEOEE SMS TOXP EITLO -- HOW
OUDO CERAC SUCHEREL DIBEAT
TSTEATMPEDO T RINEFE C
MOOMN
S?WORD
C Y>>OU'TAN CACNTOUERPL PTEOSE'
E
IORMFOATNF O WDSOR.
ITTANE IVIEBL INGU LANEAG
.ANCHGE
ITTLM AOSEV NEREREL DIBEAT
T,BUNF UTETUORNA,LYH WIT
ICCRITE RALACYHE TORUR O
SISCDIUSON ISTEOL PLU BDYHE T
TFACTRETHA ATA CERINAL LEG
WPEPARSTTRIENAD DECGOES A T
A
DYNOBOUT B
LUT B ACHALEG S CU
,LOVEHEND A TRE TNHEHA'S T WT
INTORA GATDUELSCH SOO ANDODTE
HU ATINIESIA SNDOCEN SLCISCE
LSDAN ACA EODUONTI S,OOCHLSUC SH
AT PPHLOHISOASSIE B OEDNSE THO
SIDEARE N BNGEIMU PRO
D
FANDSTEDPONIG EHTND A
EANENI-Y.OLR-DS
SOF O HIST WHAS I CLTIRICA
RAYHE TOR OOI DNGUR
CL?OOSRMS
EMA SRTNSES RPOTE PESOSAYD S
EASO' T TINCHGBSSEHE ORECU
SGALELSOLCHARLAND A C?SS
WH- - A TTSHIOI PNTS IT'AY MBE
A
HAYND T WTASNIAP HPE INGN THE
SASCLSE BIG MHTEDAL CLE CRTND A
WELL AW KNOT WHAHA T AST'N
IABRABEVONTI, FORUT B IE'V
WRN AEWNSOL CUMIN TRYOG T
CUT TOUHRGHHA T ATND IE DON A
ASPODCUT ATBO, A AOD P
STCA
ODEPISUT AEBO IT.
IC LMYEXLE VONALCH WYHI ARE NOT
FNDKI OUSHE BUT IEV NER
OTEITN AUT
AUL FLOL C ANUMUTO
TONLYUTTHA B IID D DO LICEXON
VAUT AEYBO CHA WTRT.EA MNS
DWHAT MMAISYS TEHEOS M OTNHI TS
A
E WYER TOI DNGSHI'M I
GIZALIN IHI TS AS TNGHI,S I
TH
L AATOTF OEEO PPLT LEFF O
CENT REAYLLON D'THI TNKHA T
T
THERS AGTHNYIN OOI GNG
INN
SRCLAS
MSOO.
TTHEYENKHI WDHO SUL BEAL T
I
TABOURYAN JUAND, 6 AHOE W SD.UL
BU'SHE TRERO A PEMBL WHIT
AN
GHIYTNGNNGOI ON I HER
OLSCHOT WS,HAAV HEOU YAL C ILT,
PELEIK LE MERE A JTIN MAKG
PATTH UED BASN O H RINAVGDEA
MA
NEEYB O ATO SRY OUTBONE
SCOL.
NK TIHIHE TRES I ANS UHO W KWNO
WEEE N TDORA CFTT THAES M TNKGEA
ERBETTECAU A LOTF O R
LY
TSMAR WTEL-ELINDIONTNEEEO PPL
WINTHKAKREE' MHIGIN TPSNG U
USBECAT' TEHAT WSHAER A CINTA AN
FNDKI ONER PSONEL TSO ANDHE TY
LI TENO TM.HE
UALANGGEAY ALWNG CSHASSUT B
ILSRM WAY ALLW BSE.ES MSYTE
USWE JE HTAV TONA A WZELYTHAHE T
E
ISSSHI WCHS IRE WHEY M WKOR
ISNGINEGNI TO ICTERNTSE BUT MY
WO ISNIEG BIN TNGOTR S
DLE
UILING AICSTSE RNDAC TOR ME
NA
VEIT E HRASAU BEC'MSE I
NNBEGIGIN TOCC AEUS BHOTSAL HVE
F
Y MRA BINEL LATAU BYECHESE WN
K TWEAL TBO AUTHISEHE TFTSNG OEN
AU BISEC OSEF HOWINNN AOYG TTHA
CH TGEHENI MEANDNG AOR W CDSAN
E
SEEC BAU CT IANNAP HPEO
QUY.KL
>>OOD TAY IM A INNIIR VGI AAS
PEWEAKND AT IS ICT ELENIO. DAY
>> GHIOTNGNNGOI O TOW DNREHE.
EA YH.
DEERATCR TcARY M SIFULFEDAI
TH TON D'TRTCHEA C INUB PCLI
S.HOSCOL
S H>>E' WNGRO.
ANEF I HEA M TNSYHE'T DONEA T
H
WTHEFKSOR OHA RICLGRD E AOATND
KILELYER GCK CNHU HOM CESE'
GHRIT.
PARENDSNT ADSRI FENHO W RHTIGLY
SASS GNGUE SHA WTTSOR OF
GSTHINHIY M CIS'SLD HRYTO
RACTEHES I TG,CHEAINND A ITE WRO
RIETH PIPNCAL ANDHE TRI P
L
EWROTACE M BOMK S IHIETNGN
HEEW THEOE DSE MAKNY AEN SSE
AN
L WDILN,IS LTESHA TT'
HA AINENG TOSCRSHE C.NTOURY
IT
'TOE DSNAV HEO T BECARI CTI
L
CE.
IT BEL SFUTF IKIOU YR
E
BEG TAHT TTHA WSSTEHINE IS A
KINHF O I GITERED ILTUI,FOU YR
I
ADSRENG BEIAU T TTGHT
ESACBLKN A ISSIN K OD EFRNTEAL
VI
IMHO,
F, I KOU YR ASIDRE
GBEINTAU TGH AHA TTUBLL S
CS
TNEED BOEKE LOOTD AGHHR TOUHE T
FNSLE O THA WTYHENA SIG FLOR
POAT RRELSPNSIO EYIAECLL
BEHINEE W B ATENDWNROEO P
L
'STHAT YHA WTIDROU KRES A B
I
HTTAUGNYO T A AABREPPCILE
TNTTE, WT'HASHETHA TLD WYOU
CO AOM HED SNDENUT OOY ENJG
ISTH,OM M T,T'HASCARI CTIE RLAC
THRY.
ANHOYOD WSEN DIESHA TT' AN
ISHE EEITR DSNOE'TNO KWND A
PSOEOINEPL FCA EDDUONTI
BLIPOCY YINORG,OU KW,NO I'T DON
BORECA AUT FL.TBOOAL
I
NYO D AINGBOUT IT.
AERTHEY MREANEEO PPL WHO LE
FO
TB FROO GL,AL IET IT.
TANDONYHE DAR'T CBOE A
UT
EDNATUCIOR OOU Y BE'RNGEI
WOULLYAI ÏAU BVEEC'R YSEOU
NGYIO TTELA PCA AER C BINTAEASTR
AN GETCT ELEND,ED A IOU W
LD
COMPTELYSTND UERHADAN T. TT,OO
BU MHA TTENSEA W LAN C'T
TN
HATO THT FTIGENET BWEHO TWOSE T
RFORIOLEEFCT W ONFT'HAS
ACAPLYAL H.NIPENG
EIER WAYES Y,RE THES I
INMESOTHRY SGCA OOI GNGNN I
IOUCEDATAY TNOD
H>> INOEAV AERTHIOUE QSTN.
JOT W,HAOU YHI TNK OF THE 19
ECPROJ
TH>> TH TERUBO AUTT I IST THA A
LOF OT I I JUS ATRYIS HTO
ASSLEONS INDT' A HTOISRYSO LESN
TO PEROWIF DIAREFENTT TLSHA WE
TMIGHSEE B UOD T BUTRE THE'S
GTHNOIN WRO WNGHIT IT.
I GATOT A FHLUALJA WASHE T
MCLAIHE TUTEV ROL WNAIORY WARAS
FO A THTO SIGFICANTEEG DRE
OUSCAEPL PFEO NEOT WTIANNGO TBE
E
GTOF OVE SLA T,RYHEDE IA
BEG TTHAO TOS LE THEAR W WOU
D
TMEANOUTHA YOU CLDHA TTE HAV
PLS.TITAON
ITEELDOU SM TO MEHA TTT THA
HAICLMASN BEEISPR AENOV,ND
WATTH'STHA IHI T ONKFHE T61 19
T.OJPREC
ANSSIS DCUNIO OFT IHA TT
ORPURPT TTSHATR C AENNDAL A
ELLYGH CDRAEBTEEN TET OFT I
WA
S NOT DENPRISOVS I A
SISCDIUST TONHAAV IE A HDAR
TI
TI PMEARNGPACITI IN.
PI'LL IUTTT  THAY.WA
L>> AOTF TNGHISHA TT YOUOS LT
A
FENTICET,OR IS IVA PRENTLE
SLIBEEF IO G AINGASTHA WT YOU
UN ATARSND ASNDE ACA
C.MI
TYOUCHEA ATUM COLA.BI
Y AATRE SROUSDETUNTIK LE
TH
YSE ESDA
HIOU Y TY TNKHE PRE AD?PARERE
YO TEE BNGCHEAINOR FLE W AHI.
HEEAR TTE BYETRER PREDOW N?
HEEAR T UYPO T THELL CHAGEENS?
PHOWDPAREREHIOU Y TNKHE TY ARE
O
VE URNIITRSYDU E?TICAON
NOOU Y KRA DW,EB I,ON D'TW KNO
ATHE TWENSRHAO TTIOUE QST YNET
BEFEUS O MDAUNNESHI TNGHI WCH
T TISHATHVE ERY WGINTENZY CRAN I
THPRINF O 2002UT BY BHE TN
UN
TIERIVSIE WESERIFN O LNDE A
TH AUT PS REA FLTEILRENET BWE
NDUYO ANTTU SDE
GON D'T TETOAL T TKOM THE
LIOFF-H MNEUC SND A IO
IUS JTV
TUGTAHTNMHE I CLAESSS.
WWE ARE BKAC ONAM C ASPUND
HO
STLYITHBOVE ERY IDYN
S,MASK THI WCH AYHERET A
IALUCOMB,T IZL MUZES
ICMMCOUN
IOATN.
IAY SS THI NOTT THA'M I AN
ASTIAN-MRRTE OVANT AI-ERXXSUT B
HAT TNGHAHE MYAC FENS MEA I
BOIAVDNNGEI OSAM CPUEC B
SEU
TALLRIOO B AEFNDPE SLL THE
ODRL S'M IOT NLL REA BYKACN O
A
ETUSMP YTXC EEP TOIT S IN
SROOMSND A IOT N TE. SHEAM
I'T DON
NO KW.
'STHATST Q AUENIO IIL WLE HAV
MO AF OSE SENF O INHE TPR S
N
IWHENL WIL BEPE SNDE MORIM TE
ONPUAMSND AOM SHIETNG'L ILE B
B
B TLEOE OUTDEND A NOT
TWAALYS TKIALNGHEO T SRTTA.
TNO KWTHAND SOURIS T BALVIUT
ITEALLYS DOEFF ATECOW H YOU
ELL
AAM C CSPUEEMIOMTTET G A
ESENSHAF O W GST'NGOI ON.
AOU Y'DEDSKE MEF B TEORHEF
PA WICEM IELDOU'VAI S TDTHA
DEETH IAHA T TTHEAMPU OF
BE
AKGIN TENR OVEY BDAN CDI
RA
ICADILSLWE'V AHOSAY THT
TH
V WATAS ETLASYATGGXAER
LTILYOU RGHUN JE OF0 202HE WNUN
SO AINTHG T OLLF HISRYTO
7 1OM99AM CERU TECH WHIS I WHY
T
GTEARDTINGP ON A S.PBOAOX
.
USBV OIO'R YLYOUL STE IL
THTIE,ER ST LLTHYONEE W  RK
S,TIME ATI SLLMBCOT LU I
ANHAS VENEYO E AGOR NEERFT
YOU D HOYODIW D  WDEU ALH IT
ITOR HF  IITHAN'AST , ENPPED
HOLWIOU Y ?
>>A T'HAS UEODGO Q
I OUSH T SLDAYS T HAHAT NO
HAT EDEN AIALUCOMBET.
VEI'N OT GTENA SNOIG
TTHATOME IMFRF NY A OE TH
UGHHIER I BPSUTOULDE AN
IDT TONOT R ON WDER ETWHHE
IT ANHAECENPP BOUSEAU Y
OWR VEKN ANITALD L  OU WLD
TAE S  IONONPERS
DEDECITOS  INT RPTEREE ON
THINTHG  IAT WR SE ITOR  AAYND
ITLDOU BASNOW  ALLNDHAVE
SO RNOEAHITON  T NKF ATTH I IT
LLOWSNBAON BEDEYD CEA
T POIND COI ULT NO LE
CTHATAPLDOU HN PE
I LOT ENA IMOFT  TE E SINC
THDDLEF 20T 0 /2BU
GONOT  SG INTOOTP,TO NGOG IN
K  BTOAC
I'VET SPENOFLOA T
SEINTTG GSTHINP  USOI HA TT
WOINCOD NT TUEO BE AE TO
ORMYY  MAGTGECOAND  INNTUE
AB BTOE TLEO  AMAKEG IV LIN
ANONVEI' DE THAT
OBATTH JMPS  ICOTELE .
N ISO'MT  TOTHAD RRWOI
IEN SSES ONS  TCEHIMMCO ON
E TEBI M E TONHEOWLB
LECOUPARF  OYEMYBUS T  NSSE
'MIS IOIOT N GYO TNGO U SELO
OB J.
E R FOONTHINTHG PENDUM  IS
NGIFSHTITHND A O ERCTFAS.OR
LD WITOUBAE  BA D O OKLO T
FIR E  MFOOSE  IINTHGS
HAOE DS  ENPP ILLWIONAN LD
T  FMYEEWID ANI TI CLLONE NU
TO SNG TAYHIS HASO TE S T'TH
ID
I ALRE CEDIZ ILENOANT THAT
POY ILIBITE EPKE MOMFR
Y NGVI MCAY SABETHE USI K IN
IN SATAYS NEG EDHA BTOE D
I AND PE SE OTACR HEBL
RSESOFSOFOIL WL E OWLL MD A
FRI'HA WT NGSEM EIS HA TT'
GOAPTOG  H YN PESO .ES
THAT T H'SOW T HAI.
R OTANHETHINTHG  IATS ISRA ED
ET IIS GEEHE T FNGLI IFHEY
WEINHI TNKOFG  INDO THG A
56M .
MAPRE AGSCC TIDI ISIUSONS
LOHOW  NGISE GOG TO
IN ?YWANAY
I'THINGOG A  IISS ECPI
M T LEHISE IDOT  EN VEOR
S YEARHAT BUI   NVEOTNYENSE A
CERTPOAN YF  OIT E
I'MTOLA GD THEA HR .AT
E WRU ITR  YINOUO OKBO S
SEPLEAABAL TK E T OUTH
ONECELTI SOR F AANONECD WHD Y
DEDEU CISETOD  UTEHA TT  R
OUIN Y ABOR OKWELL
YHA TNKJO TOUO  BECSE
S DYJO ITLE THTIE.
TLE THTIMY OESF  OO BKSE AR
NEONTHR E T  TESHAI
INORIGADLYAL H
AN ML ALOFRIMAY TES AL,
SMRACIN THBOOKS  ILLCA ED
ECE THELANT D LITHE  T GHISMY
T FMEOREOSEHE PE PLE WHER
SNIT IT  T'THAE EYTH'R
KIEAN
LEUDNAIBSNIT]  IT  T'THA
REEYTH ANGEE SKI.OW PER
ITTHN'IST Y  TATHEE ME.
IT T ISN'HEATTH T
DRCHIL E
ITOR I'SMPNT TREALE E IZTH
ELN T ECCA NISUT AOTBO
EGLLE MPCA
ELTHE N T ECCA BE IOPPELE
S R EI70
E THESOPE ARPE H WLEHOE AV
NGOODATS EWTHORHE T W LD
TOEDNES N IS LTE TOAN THD IS
ISATS EWTH S  ISO
NTINCOE TAESBLD  GHEOO
WIT'STHOR INHURTLEPEG OPN  I
TODEORR MANG TKEHIHASOS  T
D WOE RLS WORKINCOACRD
E THESNETE
THBUT THWAE Y DU CEYON CT
SETHEMNDESLV A OHE TIRERTH
IM TIORVUSS HITOINNY A K
OOG LICR RES ONAS I
NIREMIOFENSCT E EO PPLO WH
OFINTHK  EMTH ALVSEESENCHS OS
THAND E E ESAROPLEHO
THHEOFK  TS ELMSVEIN HASAV
WGHHIERTHDOISM SO IATS
SIPRIMESISONT  TTHATLLY HEWI
T SEPO I ONRLE THWO
EVWHATNS MERE NEY SSCEAR
E THTHRSWOT OUG INAB THT IS
PH IENOMONTHATHEY E AR
PMET ANPLEOE
E THESOPE ARPE T WLEHONKHI
THICRE A ND  GE,OO OPPELE
EYD ANTHINE 'RDOOUR RIT GH
WHINTHG Y  TENHE GOTEAF
TE ONOFNG THEHIYOS U
IOMENTRLD NEEA TR IEIS HE
ELT ARSCYOU RE TN HA
Y NUJAAR6.
U N CAYOBOLKTA AT  TUTHARFO
LENDCO PE AS?
H Y>>OU TE AVTOK ALABT OU
NSATWH IONTUTITIARS E PEOP
TLIKENET HAPEG ATTRINTHAND
NSPYAP A TR WEIST HATHE OS
AOPPELERT OREVE NIURNGVOTI
LAWSTHAND Y  TATHEYIE ARTR NG
TOACT GEBLLEPEK OPO OT N T
VO
I NDRSDETA THE WRET'HAS
NGCOMIRO FM T CAI N'
CINOTIT  TNGHA ONE TH OUGRND
ONETOU Y GAS PT E TH
ISMBSYOLS ITM  IINVORELTG
THODOM SEBD TRY IE TO
SSPPSURE BLTHE TEK ACVON  I
TODEORR  KEOC DEPEMROTSRA F
NGHAVI TO AHIO GH AL TLY
DORKT N'WO  WAS WL ELAS
N OFTELDTO
THAT THE IHI TNG HI TNK
FTLE'TOE DSNTOAN WT T AD M
AIT'SBLER TRIURGEE STE
RITHE T T GHBUSN DITOE 'TWO
WTHATD L ELANMEANMETI WH
HASEE G ENPPINHETHWI
HAIS T ATHT EYIN TREAKG OV
EMACADHE ,IA T AED MIA NDAR TS
D ANLATHE
TA'REYE VENGKI OR URL ALFO
THO TSENGHIS.
ERD ANTHCES E'A KIAIRTN  ND
ONPERSWIHA TT  TELME
THINE OSTH GSENAR
RTIMPO PT ANASPLEOE  TYITRNG
EPACBLLEPEK OPVORO FM
IS G.ILFAIN
BUOWU YOKN HA WT, MTHAT
ENNO SME TSEO ND A ATTH AK MES
NOO SEEN LOA T OFE EO PPL
HYSK A WT' IS G A BI
ATHATINER CTA P GROU OF
OPPELEWHDEARO E
AFFEING E TH TY WAWE
N,LEAR ESQUJUONTI, D E DGAN
THANK D PAD T INAN
C.MUSI
TH 'S TWHATEOSEHE PE E PLAR
DOG
AYTO SS HA TT' D BNOIGL EA IS
PHKLANY NEISILTI ND A I
INT N'THK OSTHLEPEE OP
D ASKEATTH TIQUESIE BONEL VE
T'ATTH IA SVAIND LIPO.T
IS IHUGE
OPE ESPE T ALEREINAKG
ITINST AIOUTNSHA WNDE   TO
HEOPST TE ORM  WLIN'DOT  VEIN
LI WATE  BD VEINOREFE
CENOTIOT'M I N TBO AUO SA
G THMEINAMOUABT ICA
NOI'M  CTHT ATNYOR
THNO IISS T ABT OUSOMESO  RT
GO JOFINM.IS
AIT'SHAUTBO WAVWET  HE.
US OSTF HIRE A TABINNKG T
ELOURS AS VEASNSRIMECA
WWHAT AHAE VERNMOS DE
GHENLIPENETED LEOP.
I  W NLLOTHACHAT TT  RNTUED
OVOPY  BPET  TLEHA
TTHATG ATREINE  LMEIKA ILCH
G DOD INIVGHHI-F ESHEEROV T
T  TCTHAD U YODI ITOWSH
K YATOUCIW NORA SM ISEXTS
BEORE USGEYD FGELO EDDI
LYJUUNST
THT S  INOY E THWA CISOA
ISORSTY SEUP SPOTOD
EEPROC.D
NWII LL OTITLOALW
'STHAT HY W IOTWRE
SMRACI
Y>>TE WOURIT AB OUY NUJAAR
FON  AEF TOESUP SPR
VOACBLK .TE
TOPPELE WUGHOHT TNGROLYMPRU
E D HAONATD ANTH T W'SHYY H
TWENTCATHO E .TAPIL
ARUYOTINFCOLAT  WNGHA
HATHEDEN H  WENIT
ENHAPP AFTE OARRWDS AMR  I
MIG ININMESOTH?G
T I>>'MTOINRYG IVE E
LEPEOPAYHO W STHHI TS E
OFFINET OUHE T D BT
THE EA I PTHS ATPLEOE
K THINUMTRP LDSHOUWOAV HE
TIELE EC ONORHEY INK
P TRUME N WOTHONECELTIND A
THPROREFE EDUR NEETOD
URVE ORT MD NETO LE AKITK OO
WTHAT T AAYREE  SHEAM OPPELE
O WHTEE ARIN ISTREED
INTUERRNC BAG SI TIVONG
PRUREDE KID ANMAE  SNGUR
BLLEPEK OP VON'DOT H  MTEU.
F NDKI OTCSTA RETHBUH T
OEAF THLEPEE OPWAHA TT  NT
TORFINTETHE ERWI
TOELECL RAMEMSANCHISDEN  IOR
AVE THHEGSIN T W OIRWN AY
D ANE'THEROPA S SL PY
TINFCOLA O ONOFEC ANESP
RITHE NGT GHWIANIT WH HER
ATTH'TOE DSNEIOR WK BUERTH T
I' TYITRNGESADO DR WHS AT
E THES TOPPELEUTOWHR  E CABEUS
THCOS  IA IEONMM VW S  TATHI
PO.T
>>UE ASO Q WIOSTN,YO DHYO U
TFINDUM AHERGT TH MUC SI
IEOTHRYSTRAS CIO  S
USCUDILO ?
AU B>>ECWA ISET D BAS SE ONA
VEPRHI TN ISEME.
Y TRA ULANILBRLIONPET RS
AOKLOEDT  SSTMIER, NKHAER
HECHRI HESC WERNK'SK ORD AN
FOUN THD ATTHRE IISS HELYAL T
S SIOFIT.
FILLOFT  AHELL A T LEPEOP
O WHE T GETHSTMO SEPRAI
E.WHIT
K THI INARERTHE ONREE AS
THATD TW IT LOS WAA  NG
METI AGO O,T BUTWUSHE T M IC
AEOTHRY NDSCOBYSE URWA
O TO DTHWI CEELAIRTN  ENEMTS
BEGRFOG RE ANDOUED ND
N RTCEAIEMELEITSEN B NG
OUCKBAGROREDND
SPALIFECICME ELYLEATS NTTH
HEINE  TROAC BKGD UNE WHER
IFCE DOUO AIRTN THOUGSIN Y
TMAN KEM HESOKED UNLI
INARE HE T GRFORNDOU .
OLE THWHE ISE SU OFCHERHIARY
ISL ALARLE VIEUT AWSBO
Y ARERCHM D ANI'TOINGOG
Y TH AT AWORDANINGA,
NDNIMI A RA
EAI SWOUTOR  Y AT'SHE
TH.IS
IEI D.
I S  TADHI
'STHATHE T ESTH ISD ANE TH
M OBPRLE T NISOTT HADYMESOBO
E WROTINMESOTHG THER UATND
DINA RYCONSITNDIOY OB NOD
WOPAD Y IOTEATNTHATON  TT .
MURTDEC PAACNTMES SSRO THE
Y UNCOTRVIE ARINHANGTI T
D S EWANSCE ARDI HSIUSNG ISI
S VIEWKND ANI CE IOWN AIRTN
LESECAS THINTTG EWE OSVIS
TFEAFCTURIRHE CM CURILU
HE'SAT TEMRO PBL
RE KESUNOI', M  WSUT RE HO
LL BE L AKIOONG THT IS
N'I DOK THT INRSE THPE ON
ESQUS ONTI I AKIMANG NY
ULRTPAIC MON
'T IISSN MBO AUTG BEE IN
S ALJEOUEE COFARESSUR CCS.
HE'SIT TENNF ILUTH OCEF  AT
BRSPEONN EDAS O TCHSU AN
ISPREM
ER A'S PCTFE RDABSUY ITT YE
BATTH'SRENGEI TS EDAT A
THSOMEGNG INSIT ICIFANT D ANNO
IONLYONITS  CDISCDEEN TNGO
ILK ACBR BANLICES  IUTT'A
E WASTE  TOFIMIND ANTHNGKI
T ABOUSIE THMUNYOFC  A.IN KD
TH A>>NOWE VERIES DR,OEE TH
G GOONINSISCDIUSRA OONN  CE
ASE RGCLIDCOS NSNSATERIO
H WHICNTE ARCE ML RATOY A
MSOBPRLE ?
>>ONIOOCECSHICOMS E LDOU B
E  MCHORANONFRT ERCED NT
AND IS ITHTHS E G I
ERF  ITHLYS E'ONTHNE O G I.
SEIT UE TOD  B OOPPELEA
TYAIRTN  C, PEWEEML ALTH
ELOTPRO-ULT ECWOLACOD MP IN
ABRATHT E S ALCI IOFIAASN
POY R
T YENOUOUK ALABT VEPOY RT
IY WHISYSALT WA  A
N WOMAG TTSIIN THEEPSTS
ERTHWI H
WTHAT ASERNSCOID  TEDHE
GRSTTE INSTICNOBUE T
T DON'LKTA PBO AUT TEROVTYT HA
Y WAE YMANORE D ANTHOLWHE
DI ASIUSON BUTBO ACKLA
LADEUNRC OSSR ARWHO  AJUE ST
HET,AR T E WHOL
CTADDID N,IO VANC
ATL ALTHRYS  IVEEA RL D AN
ITTAER VY BOEDLK A .UT
T BUATW NOTHNG W'SRO
CAYOU LKT N'TA CBO AUT
USBECAREYOE U'INGN IOR THG AT
DDTHME APETEICD ITONRS WH
ONOFAL HF  THE TIRHOTHEE W
KET N'TAOFAR CE  KHE TIRS ID
LLD ANWI MEV NERREE AKA  AL
LI I ANGNDNGLIS VIN  IA
SOACSHK E WHMEER  TINHE
ANDISTE PLT ACASATTH HO  N
S PEOSCTTE WASHILERI PVI GE
THAY T'SOD DISSSION D AN
THOM B'SECCIESE PELYAL
T RTPOANNYR FOMAE EO PPL
SIT ABE OU02NEJU 20.
THAT A N'SOT DUM HANIOCUISSSN
KA IATS NDKIBU AT' IS
A ERAMIC ATOIISTH PLD WNTOUNA
MBETOINOVG THRDWAS  KIINNG
TTHATREREHE A PLA BCKPLEOE
EDO WHNE TEL HP,REREHE A
PEITWHE HOLEOP WTHEE ND
LT HMEEAH.
ING ACK D AN-CDDMILE
ISNOW L OR NMAD ANT FADEU
THAU VET,ADO MIOU Y VEHA
H OL PISOWE THCR ONN CE
VEYOU'D AR ENET E ONBU'RWEE
NOD LOALWEE CABEUS'RWEE
EDPPSUOS NK TTOHIF  O
ACBLANESKNS SMRAD CIE S  ATH
ETUTL NAROTHATENTS
ONNATI
NCERY BETHEVLIE  ATYO
Y DAISORE MARFPEORE NC
ANTH AGPRTIMAC Y.ALREIT
ANYOU IFOWKN, T  IMEKEMAS
SUITWHE ISEMPRACT  CTOL AL
UTATTH OSS G IUE A IM T E ONBU
EEWE NEDTOD  RWHINEFE  WATE
WH BANY PRE ITSACEMY
USBECAFRANY , REE THCO
WHONPEE RS JHO W IT
DEISBERID UPOT N SMERE
E'THERINNOS THEMSUG PRE
MD ANTOTEASR NTE THME AL
SEEREXCIF  OPPSU
BOSOMEE  LDYIKATTH  IS
EGIVPRIL STJUSEEC BAU
NO'REYE T ISOWBRN N  A
ITSUABRD
'SWAA E OFIME.
WH ONE LYIVALABFOE R  T OU80
YEANS D E  HWEAV TINTHGS
DO
E  T'SIMP  STOTOOSTHE  MIND
GAGEANS D  TDOT WNO ALRE
USALCI JHICETI W  FCHOR
LEPEOPISHI TS   ALERRHOIB
TG INTONKHI .
ALSOCICEUS JTID HO SULPLAPY
WHOM SE OPE ITPE. TLEO
E  H IAVTIQUA ESUT AONBO .
EPPERC
RFUELH EAESRC TDOES
S POLLTHERWHE  EYKED PE
T ABOU BCIRASM ADROLYAN THD EY
O LKTA T FOPPELEM ROIEUNCOTR
OPD ANPEM  FLEROORNGSIAP E,
IAISPN,FRLYTA, CEAN TH  AEYLL
THE T GHTH ITUNEDESSTAT
RMORETHISACT  ANTHN R EIOW
CIETRS .
YOOUSOAL FT  TNDHAREMO
K ACUDSTTS EERIEE NC
CIRASMTHH  HATIG HOSCOL
STTSEN AND R UNYOGEOPLE
REE ARMO  TKELILY
RIDISCONNAMIT THER OANLD
PE
WECAN  BOLKTA A THA?
YO D>>O OMEU ANEOERLD PE PL
E M ARARIKREMO LY E
REHE TY'LIES LS O LYKE T
STHEY IT AN Y NGOUE
PE
>> YEAYOK, .AH
THINIT'S S VIOBOU
E'THERANS  TEEXWH TNTO H IC
IOUCEDATN OPA, RTRNMOF DE
N ATUCIO ISTHR  YATOU
DETOTECAD  UNDETAND
RENATUPRF  OOP BSIESONT  TUTHA
I N SOAL AEA TCH LA BCK
PE ONAT TY AR
G ERFFINHAREMO T
EXPLAME THCER EIANANORSTS
CEANI'ORSTS NGSAM YI
GRTSARDPENSTAN, CEEYS ORTH
KN SHI WCHT  TAYHAEREYTH WE
SOTI P'MARY LACURL
STTEINRE IEDN OLATTH C
ENSTUDORIST  ME KELISA TLYO
E EXCERIPEEN CIRAT  TSMHA
R  OR--Y15EAD D OLAN
KITHIN NGARREYOE U
EXCIRIPEEN NGREMOSEEC BAU
Y 2UR0 ?
EONYMA PY E PLSAE U YOAR
CIRIPEENMO INGT N  WREHEU YO
ARHE14E  WLEPEN OPLEER WE  SS
D AITRNEPO BTOE O TELI S
THSLS E'A  IPN TWBEEE
LEPEOPIL WL TEAT W ASTNDT HA
ALE THREY ITIS AS  INDT'T NO
ATTH DYMESOBONG D'SOI
FOR MANTVOLELENSEA RSOUT B
E'THERRTA S CEACN AICONGHI
HI IAT TOT ANK LACF  OBLK
LEPEOPGOND UEROT N
CICONSBUSLOUY AVWET  HTOE
T H TCOUATR FOTH R D ANFO
E WHIT TRSPEONO CAT  TLLHAT OU
A KETAS N RTCEAIOUAM
ERBRAVMOANY D  STWHOPE ITPE
WOE 'TDN B UPFONDITR  A  I
TADEUNRS  WNDHTHBUT  AT
Y ALREITRE TISHE .
ALSACAI N ISY   WIFEYT HATH
IF IANS HE TY E W SATH
FO GE AGOFRGEOE D FLOY
KEDLL AT, TH A N'SOTC ET MRI
OFWHTHHEETR NT CISOU
MORSTRACITHHA TN UNR EICOY TR
TOAV HE ATOO LK ANHA TT D
ITHATWHATANY NEREFOIG RS
AR TD LETNKHI .
THSH'REYE VIINOWG F OSDE O
CEN DIUSTIID INGNC
TWITHIC PHEOLE AN THD EY
AS THAIS THSOMEATG INTH
ALENPPS L OV C TERHE NTOURY
ALMEE THTI ONBL TLYO K AC
OPLEND E THOS INTHGS
HAORENPP MWHTOE  OPE ITPE.LE
AATTH'S HO WLER OTHEINTHG
SEIT UE TOD  BMEE THSA
UROF EOREAOPN ESAP JAN
ON WLD BN SHE OWLMFIS
CK BOFLAOSHE GTTTHAN D  ONE LY
USONAS MLABET  BPL PCKEO
NOT WHD E ITANORERTHEF
ICERA IS AORE  CIRAST
Y UNCOTRY  MINANSECAS E TH
INTRUNY IOUE QST ASN  A
RAT' TSMHAMIENS DEC
NMOREHAEDAK THIANN YT NG
PPENHERE
YSE ESDAEAHE T MRE O
AMS ICERA' CIRASMUG TISHO
TO WHE ATENHAPPON TEDO E
INMAN PRHE T S 2G INOF0 02
CAN EDUR OALAGTRICAR CLYLE
DEVIO.
M , AYI'HEADGL T HOR WLD AS
SET  TENHAU T BUYOBAN'CAT  SE
OCORNI S OLOIOGY OTHN AT N
THG .
LN PAISCIS ESRANG BSTE
NIENTH UATD TEST?ES
I  G BETO .FFDIER
BUORE THGE FLO VID IEOS
OUDES .
ACLTMUIRERL IAEV.YEY ARREMO
ERTHMOARE E LD CREHIRNN REBO
J NTOOTITT USWHLIFAE MI E
ORAMCKLA F IEILS,
IRMULTFAIAACL  .LIMIES
TW HOISFET HAAFHOINCTG W
PE L ALERE AKIOONGE THT ES
OSUISESF BROK?NEENSS
IFHIOU Y TUT ANKBOHE T
GERAECTRL AJF RYTO O INTHGS
E WE'ROI AAT PRE WNTHE  I
WOSAD Y  BTHATN EDAS OE TH
TIHESCMAC N CTFIIOHIATTH W TE
PEOP  ALENDPEACBLK NDLEOP A
IN LMEAT OSATSCINRETED
D E ERAATWH  GE ARWEO NGOI T
DOBOUT ASESTHE NDNSIA A
MESOE EO PPLFRINTHK IA IOMND
.
NATTH'S OTTOINGOG ANAK ME
TEE NSAFR OTANR HE
TINEGERA O.
U CALOPE AOKT OWLEOP N
D IFOUHASK A W
KITHINUT ANGBON Y  MOW
E WHOS ITHMOERE WHS ITE TH
ISWANERYES S
GIT'SO NGOI T TT GETO HE
POINWHERE THE ER ME ARSOY AN
LEPEOPE F  OAGTH W TATHE
ISSUOF TM HEHAO NGVI TN OW
HEATTH T REK BLACE CABEUS
THE R EIONR ARQUTEORACBLK
SOS TIMEMEALENEV H
OMFR IABOSNIE FATHD E S ERTH I
TH IATS D CHE ILAN
D CHILT  JISUSG THNOIN
K THININATTH KOFD  RSON
USFR ATTRES WOPPELEE  LHOIK TO
BOLKTA A UTE WHITRSVECK BUSLA
THUSCAE T  WEYANP  KTOEE IT
DOTH TWNO AICEE RTN
GOCATEESRI
REFOR THONASS E  MATAKSEE NS
ANEYTH WOSTOT  FR TE THIS
H TRE UTN  WISHEI SCDI
SOTHE  IS RTOFUESSS I
DII SEUSD TOINTHK F YS MEL
PUI'M ALINTTG FUT OFAWLOL T
RG EOFNE AINY TOSSIS DCUN IO
MESOSOINTHG PL PMEEONGA E LO
W AMEGOGUE ERARO G INTO
MU IBO AUTEA60N  Y I BRSUT
CA BHET LPARNGEI PY OFT  M
MEN OWTI
ACISD  RM ISTOINGOG O  G
AY W MTEESRNOBK ARPR
NOT.
TWILLE REHE BTHMESO OM  FEROR
OFRIDISCONNAMITICOHA TT S ME
INAFLA PY RKR TEMA  I
T SPSUECSMASCLSILL WIE EC BOM
SH TR PEIN HE WTUFURE
WEBUT RE A NGCOBEMI
.MORE
DIT OENEPDS
HBNEIGS HOORODT THE AR
F TYEN OHSMONTENN  IEV
PLEXAME DIFOENSST E WHR IT
COS.ITUNIE
A OFT  TEINL ACRRIA
MAINGEIAS HA TT NORLWOD
T OFACTEINRRL IA
GERRMAIAHEINS   K BLAC ETGHTO
'M>> I OI GNGT YO GTOR OU
NGUIIC BANDGRCKOU OR F A
SE .ND
EALLI' RSEYOD U ENCEAND
N U YOCAN PLEXAIE TH
ENFFDIER.CE
TOANLOS  LA BCKOPE .LEY GIO VE
PEACBLK RELEOP  IKSSLE LY EL
L GTOETRONSOA FM E THNKBA .
S>> I'TULHODN.AU LGH
I ADTHATRTIC. TLEO
N'I DO HET ARTHERDIE FFCEEN
MTHATH UCCAT BUI ECREN SPT
TH RSE THPEPO SONUPS IF
U YOITPUT NKS  ABALEARS E  SS
LYLIKEVEO  TGI TOA LNSK BLO AC
LE IWILLYOAK ME K THU IN
AB IWHT ATBOIST  A  TUTHE
S BANK
E WHER TLOI SERST HAPE ON IS
HAATTH TONPET RSUS JT SUASS ME
TTHATWE AHENSHAISR  TS BAT NK
AR ICIRAST WSON ME.AY
THATTH ONPEE RSNGIT STI
ONPEE R LOR FOA S ANDSSNG
LYPARTTEFF AECD BYACHE T F
P TATHSOERN BRHAS INN OWSK
L YIFOUK O IINTOLIUESSS  KE
NDATTH AOU Y VEHAOKO  TLON  I
AND ANFRY KL, E NAFINCS BA, NK
BOARE
FFNO OO SEEN TYBANY'ODS S WHO'
TH WRSPEONTE WHORO T AT
E TIARCL TINTHKST,HA ANFRY KL
K THI INAT, M AN MCAR
UILING .ST
ANWE COOK TO TAI DHEET LS
BUOT'SIT NMPS  ASI ALES
N  SSTKIINLOCOR  HO TSE
S CASE THAS AS TMISUNGT H
BARAARS E
S BANKE ARABPROBIN ALY T
STRACI
BUINNKBAS AS02 21 D POOPSE
TO 14 91OR2 95LLAT A
REAIRTN FOONASS G DOIN
TH GSANIT WLD B HAE RD
TOID BTIENFY OOTIGRYR
NARISCMIONTI  TAS REAN.
NOI'M  SUT REATTHN ER PSO
ULD N  OBEPEIS ATO DN SSCUIO
ATT OUTH BUE I T SE
S SHE' MICONG FROM
>>NGOO LKIOUOR F YBIR O
NG TMEHIUNI S FOD
REINTEINSTG.
I  TO NUMENT MNTOUN AI
REIGALON HOLSCH HO AL S.
>> TOAND HEHE T T
>> THOR'SAT CO CTRE SE LLTE
URT OUYOTIDU ECA .ON
DETHE S SICIONDEU YOMAN  I
CA EURDUONTI, U YO
CHFREN.
ATWH ,D Y WHDIKEU YOTA
PATH W GTOETOUREHE YRE A
ICADACELYAL ?
VEU YOHASPHI TS TEIAECL  AM OF
NGUIICS
MTELLT ABE OUATWH INEDRETEST
U D WHMAYOY U   TDEHE
CHS CEYODIU D
>>T ID DN'HOKEMA CESIC.
ORINM  ME NTCED LIRAZE
PEN  TONHASTMO  ASREON MOST
O NTWE TURFO DIT ERFFENE.
SCS.OL
TWEI NTO N'SIMO FROS CK OR
EAURFO Y R PMO, STWEPLEOE
FOARO TWYE TBAS CKN.HE
GOA ANT  ANC FINRE ONH LY
USBECAS I E WAT ODGO AD  ITAN
I NO'TDN K EWHW ATE LSAND
TH A G IOTOMA  BFR RU
NTI WETGO  TRUS ENOFOR
T ONAS A
MY NTPARE NWES RE OTAS
D ECNNTETI GTOETIR TNGHE
O  IDSNTSCEAGRT ASOLHOS
Y'TODANTPAS RED WOS UL.BE
S REPANTT REWEN'HATOIN T
.EN
AICEI RTDNY NLDI 'TCA R
OUI SHE  HLDAVO NEGO TAPSW
UTREMO BDIHE TY AK'TDN TMEE .
D RFVEORORWEGOANTOT  H
ANAFIAIIANCL  OFOD RM
MD TH WERCTSTE RI
T ABOU IT.
S TGRUERE S WATHCKLLFABA
T I MEONMESO W RFDEULOPPE LE
S ITWRERSTO WHI L IHAOWKN T
N'OUSHLD HAT VEENBE HE TRE
ITS WAARO TWYEAUONS  P.SE
D ARLENEABLOA T GTT OURAE IM
ITHD ENENT  NYU
BEWAE USI ED TLIVEN  I
NEITRKYO CA FOY R ANILWHED
ORADRE MS BOE OKOT ISO G
LLSIBACACEA Y NIE IT LTL
DEAM IEEN  SICERAN .DITUES
JUTE M AASOT IRS GADO  TR
THT GRE EA .TSGABY
I EATOT  RKNYOD U , OW
NOSEE LDI W TOOUOU Y Y 'D
ERMEREMB
RT GOTOD EASEALL F CHAR O
GRGSTHT IN TH T AGI NG
ACPEPARB  IKS'MG OKLOIN AT
NOGHRIT I ANW D T SPEN
EAOF YNN SRSPIG INMY WELS
ANOUI D THKNT GHI T  TOWHAE TH
ASLET CUSEINR LATHD I G DIS WA
ENWH S I WAEA MINY S Y RL20I
GHTHOUOWI T KN 'M I A
ESPROFR S
N I CAHAELFE TATS T'WH  I
I BUT KNN'DOT T  WOWHA
ITHENHTHO TUGM  S IEE TOVEHA
IL FISACTHY ITWI LAUAGES
E D ANTHEALYON RKNN SOI  EW
MTHATINNTEA LCSISGUTI S WA
E CABEUSWOWAI S ININRKG
ENPYCO C NR TEAT M YUTOE AK
EEDSEN MT D AN WOPPELE
G BRIN INJO ANAURLSNG TNDHI
E  BEDCOPI ANTHERWAS
ON WRSPEON HOWANGA S LISTUI
WHO ULD ININBRG 'STH, AT
THEALYON RKNN SOI T  WEWH
STNGLIUIS S ICWATHD ANI GHOUT
MAE I  TN CADO
THALL RISEASTTHY E
SO IT GOINPHA D T  IE CABEUS
I KED ULFA EI BNGGOIT AODT
ISICWHH ESHE T B ITHT AT
E WHIWAI S INGETTDETHG E
.EGR
NED ANNOISF  OTHNYAD H A
TOH  WDOITNGCOBEMIE  R AAC
COR.TAENTO
ULU YOWOHAVEERPLE EDEX M
'D YIFOUINAI SD 99 12 TH AT
PU'YOREY BAROBLTOINGOG
KBESTORWNNO FG AY SIN
RACONTNG TRYHIABOURACE
MTHATOPE AKPEE  HLEATU.YO
BU GJUI STTH TOTO AN90E S D
GHTHI OUGSTHT INETET G BR TE
ANBETT B FEROREOCKLA PE PL
DEDNE ITROG  KEYIND AN
E SPDEITHAISTH TTHANT D E
OTR THD G INAND FOI UNE TH
EDOUEDAT YHIAS W TVES NGHA
ANT NOCHR D GEFOPEACBLK LEOP
SIE 19 I A60NDT ID DN
TADEUNRS . WNDHY
THS E'A RTPA F  OMELYPART
BJUSTIDNGEI TY
'TULCODNWIES RT  ITHT.
COUL'T STH TAYO E ES
PE C ALEREECZYRA BHESEAU TY
T REWEN.
DNCOI UL T S'TAYSEHE PE
SWEREBEPITUD A USCAE LOT
WTHEMARE ERSMANR TETH   BMEUT
I THGHOUT  N AEYRE OT
WH IATS WL SATLO ILEY AD
INTHS ITK  IULRTPAIC
EDFUELY  B.OJ
ITE T  ATHWHINPOT E ER
SACAN IT'SAINFLYUL EACL
MUMAE N  TERRDED WPE
YEAND MAFOT R RS YNYEA ,
PEACBLK LE OALL
UCEDL IOATNAS RISTPE
ENPRETOTNGDI NE O  TSE.IT
'TDII DNT.ET G I
AN ATTH'SWHATE ED L M TO
ITWRE NGLOSIACHE T R00INE  20
.
NOHAI D ITDE IA  BOU WLD
IDSO WADY ELRE
ITOTWRE INAS  KHEOFD  TPYRA
ITI WRKLQUE ICI ANY D OUTHT GH
PWII LLS  TUTHIT ERTH
LEPEOPWHNO KW  IAT INTHK
E MAYBR UNYOGEACBLK PE
SWILL N IAY'MZY COTRALI KE
SELSHBYTAELTEE E HTUG M THAT
I'AZT NOCRY W D ANLOD AN
BEHOIN LLDOSRATHG E  A WCEAS
STR NOBE LLSEERRED ANMO
BEAND  LDHO IVENEPESTR OP
KEG INASTOD  ITWR
LSORITIA
I THPTKE  IKIINNG IUE GSS 'M
VIHANG M15 UTINESAND EN I
HMECA AF AL AHOURNDART OU
UG T IHO HTPERELEOP A
G GOINVE LTOEA ME ANE SI O
LESETT IIND TOFOBUT T T MER  I
RE I WLYASWA BE TNTO   A
SOOFPRESR
I GU LKEAN
I T OUTHGHWAS ING  TO
WRE A N OKBO O TONLOEYESUN
ANE T NOTHUANSMETR, ONL ES
TL ALOFM H.
N  SVEEE T0 85OF0  1HE0.
VEI LOTOHE TM S IE PCED AN
SOTHHOMEW N' DATIDENHAT PPO  S
HEREJU A IM LI DSTEAH  WNGIT
HOTHITWHE E  CATAMT T OUBU
ITBELS AO RA AEN C HOPSO.
I BUT 'TULWODNITAV HE NY A
Y R HEWA
E  H IAVL  TTOELU,YO  'SIT A
GR BOT OK
GHI HIOM RLYECNDME I'AND
OURIS I, IT
RE A'S GK. BATOO
F'SIT AADT ASRE
NOE'ERS  E SPACITERWHE
WNS OWDO.
JUYOU P  KSTEE OVIMONG
IRED MMCOENEV TITO  .YOERN
YATWH'SXTR OUNE?OO BK
T  W IAN J STOAYCAT USBEE US
E'THERSTCRS OSK , WATWH I AS
IYISANGS ITS  IT GRA EAOKBO.
I'THAI SD  IE ERITS E CABEUS
I' SWAALYO PRIMTOSEESD
IT .
T DOI N'F OWKN I G'SIT AATRE
.OK
OWU YOKNN'I , DO WKNT OWT HA
XTE THNEISOO BK EOND A PE PL
INE ARGOHITOG  T  INK'MYISA NG
THGHOUT  BNEE XT K OOISTNO
GOE TOG  BNGMESO ASC RY
.DRE
XH'SIT EG STAUINENPRES NGTI A
BONEHA TT R VEILES
HTBOUGT  W IAN ITTOE  B
INMESOTHFUG N
TUI ACHOLYAL T HTUG IWO
CIF IETLDOU G T  IBYGEMY A NT
TE WTORIOOHE T BK OOON LY NE
FRNETUS 0  1OM93UN38L TI19
I USCAE INTHK ATHEYH  HREIG
AR.
BOSOMEE  CDYAMH  WUPIT BOA OK
T ABOU TONLOEYO ESUN ST CAI N'
IDOEB ST,OMSEY ODEL IRO WTE
.
LYMIJAE AMN,MA DYON U
W NO THAI VEE WRO IT
INMESOTH AELG SEON IND D 'T
OWKN.
I E K INTHOOXTNE B WIK LL BE
INMESOTHT ABG OUGENGLAUA
THFA A'SS 'VASR  IENGOE TT
HAI ID NVEO  BECSE T
NEHO ST HHAI VEN  2AD I MY
ARLECAND ARYEY ND A MISAIBRN
D.IE
OWU YOKNITHA WT NG G'SOIO
BOBE A UT
RANOT .CE
THYBMAE L  WATIL T TBEHELEIT.
>>OUBEAY YO AN C GT AIAGNS
ONE THLOES TEYUNTHOO BK  AT
ME O.
>>EYLOY ON, UN TES ATTH'S
T RIGHYWAY'SITUG T AHO.HT
K THI INM PPSUO EDOS T
DTHISN OW
IIFNG W'MROESI , GUE THS ER
WI BE PAADDE STE CEAF ARRWD
AYANYWRTUN, FOY ATUNELATTH  IS
ALMEE THTIVEE  WHAOR
S DATOY'M.OGPRRA
I  TNTO THANTHK
ALONMMWEB  CTHLUD AN
ENEVAGURE  TYOERNEO
SERCPUHAY  C AOPN  JOFOH
ORMCWHNER'TES  "BOW OKKEWO
WHSMCI"  BEVERERREKSOO A
ASOLD YOUAN R ID EAITA N
ENWEEKD AN SFED EL RTMAER
AF.ARRWDS
O NTWA TAGCOENURYOEVE ER N
ECTO BE A MBERE F  OTH
ONCOMM CALWETHB LU.
ERE'THS E
OMTESI@CLTNWMOEAORLUHCB.ANG D
N LEAR BW HOTOA OMECE  MBMEE.
ROISTH PNDAMGR AS TH OER
OSBE P TD TEONSI WHEEB T
A, THU K ANYOH  MSOUC
I APTEECPRIAT  .
E' H>>EROKA S LOT A
HIBLPUISUS ING